hey guys Mary here at PAX Prime 2015 and
we're working with the mix to give you
guys from the sweet indie games that you
might have missed and I am here right
now with James and Michelle hey how's it
going hey good thanks for being here and
you guys are from skål studios and today
you're gonna be showing me salt and
sanctuary yes yeah yes a salt and
sanctuary it's a 2d action RPG a lot of
focus on character building a lot of
focus on and really precise exacting
combat a lot of a lot of giant bosses
and intimidating monsters and
exploration you know very very much
inspired by Metroidvania and the souls
now we missed the character select
screen but you guys actually had the
opportunity to choose different types of
characters what kinds of builds can you
guys have yeah so you can totally
customize your character with looks as
well as so you have a starting class but
after you choose that class you can
totally customize there's a big skill
tree you can go on to really any branch
you want to I think we had like seven
starting classes right now but it's like
it's totally freeform character building
okay and who are you playing us right
now so we selected a mage just to start
out as I can show you this skill tree
really quick you can't I can't put any
points into it yet oh wow this is a
gigantic tree and it sort of look like
path of Exile in here
we actually we're hearing that a bit and
we actually haven't played it but oh
that's massive yeah well it's amazing
how much customization you guys are able
to give the character so that everyone
feels like they're playing a unique
build right all right so what are you
doing in this world this incredibly dark
very colorless world so we just got
shipwrecked we had a mission that was
gonna save the world all warford and
very poetic
and we survived a shipwreck around this
island
we basically failed our mission or so we
think okay and an hour now we're
exploring this horrible island full of
horrible things meeting a lot of other
shipwreck survivors everyone's sort of
trying to figure out what the what the
deal is and we came across a keep that
that's called the festering banquet it's
basically a party that went on forever
and ever and everyone kind of stopped
living and continued partying and now
it's just a horrible mess and we're
we're cutting down all the rotten
walkers that fill the halls yeah but
they don't like you though that's just
yeah they kind of opinions I mean they
just they just do their thing yeah
you're just trying to explore and these
guys are attacking you you don't really
know why but at least at least you're
equipped to deal with it and what kind
of stuff were you picking up from them
so some of them have pouches of salt
some of them have items that are useful
to you and then this salt is some what
is your experience so you collect that
and then turn that salt into black
pearls which then allow you to put
points into your skill tree okay so you
actually want to get salty and this
anyone want to go salty yeah I think you
picked up in here - yeah
that's a transmutation material okay if
you ever you know meet an alchemist
there's gonna be tons of armor and
weapons that you can choose from and
also change them into other weapons
using the parts of your phone enemies
yeah the current count I think we have
like 600 items in the game so far it's
just it's growing like crazy how many
people do you have working on this where
you can have so many different types of
builds and items like that so we have uh
we're them here just us - oh my how long
you guys been working on this I say
about two years we announced it one year
ago last pax okay you should pick up
that bottle oh yeah so we're actually
online right now so we can review yeah
we can view messages left by other
players
none of them makes sense like no one
leaves any helpful messages are now
we're getting into Dark Souls territory
a bit where they're just basically
trolling you are you able to vote up or
down comments or they just are where
they are right now it's just yeah it's
just uh it's just a horde of weird
messages these candles here and the
heads on spikes up here are things are
the heads are people who have died there
are there people in the real world you
know the candles candle here indicates
there is a boss at and this is how
difficult the bosses it's a ratio of how
many people had ago been able to defeat
him they got skewed skeeter yeah this
one I mean it's like we have a really
really closed friends and family and
some streamers alpha okay and one of the
streamers was like just he just kind of
wanted to test some constraint so he
died like 60 times his boss so that's a
few the average because it's only
so many result well I think there's no
doubt that this is a very difficult game
so is there any way to pick up more
health along the way how are you able to
survive yeah depending on your Creed you
have different kinds of healing items
like it I can use right now okay
and that'll regenerate every time you
revisit your sanctuary okay there are
also red shards which are more
consumables that you can buy at
merchants or find around the world okay
maybe it's something that people could
find comparable to estes lasts and gems
where you can there's things that are
always replenished every time that you
need to restart but when you do restore
the game does everything come back are
you ready the game did begin as it was a
question of what would a 2d Dark Souls
feel like great so we've just you know
kind of begin as an experiment and
everyone that showed the demo to is like
you've got it's not a sheep it's so it
so here we are two years later and it's
really becoming something else what was
the inspiration behind the black and
white style so we that's kind of been
our style since the first games that we
launched so the dishwasher series was
our our games and that was very
monochromatic as well and then he
couldn't tell them it's just how I draw
a [ __ ] job it's yeah but it's also
also somatically it's you're in this
dark and dreary world and then when you
go back to your sanctuary which is
really your one place of refuge it's
more colourful as we're Friday
supporting and you're taking away health
I noticed your your health is capped
lower now right so as you fight and as
you take damage your maximum stamina
yeah I wanted to see you beat it yeah
your maximum stuff yeah health and
stamina will be reduced over time mostly
as you use magic very punishing yeah
yeah it's all manageable through items
and stuff you probably reproduce your
maximum health well thank you so much
Michelle and James for showing us that
it looks really cool when can we expect
to see salt and sanctuary so we don't
have it really sounds like you want to
add 10,000 more items and expand your
skill Travis wants to but we all right
but this will be coming to PC when it's
ready as a launching Karis on ps4 ps4
and then yeah it'll be it'll be on PCs
really awesome thank you guys so much so
that was salt and sanctuary if you guys
want to check out that game more wow
where can they find out more about your
game so we're at pax right now or um
booth number until we forget but we're
we're actually right near the Dark Souls
3
statues so I bet those doors that you go
in on the right side or right we're
right between gunner optics how fitting
yeah awesome and for the rest of your
game news be sure to stay tuned to games